Ciao ragazzi Sono al Lucca e sta
piovendo ma la pioggia non ci fermerà
perché oggi sono qua per l'evento di
five night at Freddy che sta per uscire
al cinema quindi vi porto con me Let's
go l'incontro ragazzi l'abbiamo fatto in
Piazza San Michele ed eravate in
tantissimi È stato incredibile perché
era tutto adibito a tema Five United
Freddy ed è stato un Evento pazzesco
cosa divertente di tutto questo è che
non mi sento per niente
osservato ma non è finita qui ragazzi
avevamo appena iniziato perché poi siamo
passati a fare le interviste Una volta
finito l'evento abbiamo fatto il red
carpet dove ho firmato foto autografi
Neanche fossi un attore di Hollywood e
dopodiché siamo entrati nel cinema per
lo special screening di five night at
Freddy con tutti quanti abbiamo visto il
film e ho parlato anche sul palco Grazie
ragazzi e
niente